pour vous alors à faire un truc très
compliqué là c'est une interview dernier
coup chanter
donc vous allez me répondre en chantant
je vous dis par exemple dernier coup dur
c'est sympa j'ai quand même dit
jamais une fille qui était vraiment
jolie mais elle est partie avec mon
meilleur ami très bien fait mais en plus
il est sincère parce que c'est pas loin
d'une vraie dernier coup de tête
j'émets une autre fille et aux poubelles
j'ai tout donné j'ai tout laissé j'ai
tout laissé tomber
et puis maintenant je perds la tête du
dernier coup de poing mon meilleur ami
j'ai été le bois ensuite je lui ai mis
une droite dans sa gueule et il est
tombé
il a fallu l'hospitaliser sous forme de
puisque les musicales en fait gagné coup
de foudre
j'ai rencontré une autre fille mais
celle là elle avait un chemisier rose
elle voulait savoir quelle était mon âge
elle s'est trompée mais peu importe car
je crois qu'ils se passe quelque chose
entre nous
la scène où seule la dernière question
dans les brouillons dernier coup droit
c'est tout à l'heure vous ai pas mis sur
nous les couilles en or allure allemand
il faisait soigner laetitia rémi madec
cela aux ide l'ex vous êtes venus pour
l'émission sept à huit ce prénom est
devenu pourquoi paris pour voir une amie
ah bon comment vous êtes vous retrouvée
quel est votre numéro de portable
bon alors maintenant l'heure est grave
on va faire le blind test vous restez
avec